welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar do you have the
gun on the chip presented by dr.
aluminum obscure scientists of
application development
mammatus the organ on a chip company my
name is Xavier guitars and I will be
your moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots lab
roots is the leading scientific social
networking website and producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
now before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop down box our speaker will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentation and if you
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming dr. now Mosca I
went out in the presentation over to her
so hello and good day everyone and
welcome first I would like to thank the
organizers for inviting me for to
present this webinar on growing perfuse
the PTO tubules in a parallel
microfluidic platform
I would start my first slides with the
mission of momenta and that is to
provide human and tissue mop organ
models for the 21st century therapeutics
and with this we are hoping that we will
lead to a better medicines and
personalized therapies for the future
today I'm going to talk about our
intestinal models and I would like to
start with addressing some of the
limitations of occurence models then I
will introduce you to the organo plates
which are the platform that we use to
create this models then I will go and
dip on how do we develop intestinal
tables on a chip the available essays
that can be used with this models and I
will show you a little bit of the
results that we have gotten with a
compound screen I will also talk on how
you can add complexity in the organic
life and in the end I will explain it to
you how you can also start using the
platform in your lab
so the current in vivo and in vitro good
models are lacking in certain aspects
preclinical research remains an
important tool for drug discovery and
validation of new therapeutics an animal
models so far have played an important
role however in most of the time they
have limited use in predicting the
clinical relevance one reason can be
that animal models metabolize drugs and
are affected by disease differently than
humans they cannot accurately
recapitulate the human condition simply
because they are not people into these
conventional models to the conventional
models there is a problem because cells
do not behave the same in 2d as in 3d
and most of the models of the intestine
lack the important transporters which
are fundamental for studies
moreover when cells are seeded on
artificial membranes we do not
recapitulate the normal physiology these
are artificial membranes that produce a
physical barrier and there is a lack of
cell to cell and cell KCM interactions
which normally happen in proper micro
environments
you
another thing to consider is that 2d
cultures need a long time to
differentiate and mature and for some
can take up to 21 days of constant
testing to be ready for essays and this
is mostly done in a low throughput
format meaning that there are only 6 to
24 replicates at the same time this is
also connected to high reagent
consumption moreover in static 2d
cultures there is like a flow which is
known that it's needed for proper
differentiation
you
so what we think here at new metas is
the right way to go is not to use to do
cultures or animal models but rather try
to recreate the in vivo situation in the
human body as good as we can
you
the way to do so is to provide the 3d
environment to our cell cultures as
close as possible to the in vivo
situation because it is widely known
that ECM composition can serve many
functions such as providing support
segregating text issues from one another
and regulating intercellular
communication another thing that we
consider is an applying flow because
flow can emulate physiological micro
environments experience in vivo and we
also play close attention to providing
the right cell-to-cell communication
between the cells when we build complex
co-culture models
you
to set this up we use your gano plate
which is a 3d culture device that is
developed here at my method and as you
can see by the images it looks like a
standard 384-well plate and that is
because this is a standard 384-well
plate on the top part meaning that is
fully compatible with all the standard
laboratory equipment however when we
turn the plate we can see that there is
a special part about the device which is
the bottom compartment this is made of a
sandwich of two glass plates which are
microscope great in between these glass
plates their walls that form the
microfluidic channels moreover their
holes drills in the top glass plate that
allows access to the micro fluidics
changgil underneath the layout is
designed here at my method and we are
also flexible in producing different
designs and the one that you are looking
at is the three-lane format this means
that there are three microfluidic
channels in this plate and approximately
four not approximately exactly 40 of
them so for small experiments at the
same time we also have a two-lane design
which has 96 chips
on this image you can see the two lane
formats meaning they're two microfluidic
channels and the wall of the micro
fluidics
which is in bloom embedded between the
two glass plates what you can see in
this image are three two lane chips here
to add the extracellular matrix we use
the specialized technology to fill this
microfluidic channel which is called the
phase guide and in the image it
represents this in green line it is
basically a small Ridge between two
microfluidic channels approximately one
quarter of the height of the
microfluidic channel and in functions as
the pressure barrier the extracellular
matrix in this image is represented in
red and as we have the red ECM in the
first ship the ECM enters by capillary
force and its fold into the channel the
phase guys prevents this overflowing to
the next channel because of the surface
tension of the liquid this can be done
by any extracellular matrix that is
liquid at lower temperatures and get
solace at higher meaning that you can
create a layer of ECM with or without
cells in one of the compartments while
keeping the top compartment empty
you
you
leaving the top compartment free is
extremely important when we want to make
intestinal tables on the left side you
can see the organo plate and an artistic
representation of the three lane chip
and underneath there is a schematic
representation of the procedure for
tubal feeding and how does it look in
the different plane we have the ECM in
red and the cells are represented in
dark blue in the first step we add the
extracellular matrix which enters the
channel and runs into the phase guide
which prevents it flowing into the other
compartment once they cm dilated we then
add the cells we suspended in medium in
the top channel cells are left to attach
to the ECM by gravity after which we
start applying flow what we have seen so
far in all of our apt wheel and
epithelial cultures tested is that we
don't just form a boundary structures
against ACM but they also form a tubular
structure in that channel on the right
you can see also the existing
impressions of the - both groaning -
line formats on the top and a three-lane
format in the bottom line
the great flow we make use of a rocker
platform by simply placing the plate and
there is no tubing or pumps involved the
fluid flows through the tissues going in
the organic plate is driven by gravity
leveling by simply lifting one of the
sides higher than the other on defined
intervals we are recreating a volume
difference and we create a
bi-directional flow in this manner to
the media to make it go continuously the
plates are simply placed on the
perfusion rocker inside on an incubator
this perfusion worker features the time
program designed for their glamour plate
but for evaluation purposes the standard
continuous rocker platform can be also
used
and this is how a 3d reconstruction of
one of these two balls look like in the
bottom part we have the perfusion Lane
which there is a lumen we have
representation of the phase guide and
the gel as you can see since these are
tubular structures they're also
accessible from both the basal and the
ethical side
a great theme of the organ or places
that we don't have to limit ourselves
only to tubular structures and in this
overview you can see part of the models
that we have developed using your nano
plate in the left you have the tubular
structures like models of the intestine
vasculature and kidney however we can
also see the cells into the
extracellular matrix and have models of
the liver brain and to grow organic in
gel and if we combine these two features
we can also have a complex co-cultures
like the blood-brain barrier model that
we have the kidney clearance model and
then the thulium parasite model however
in my talk i will only focus on the
intestinal models the
why're intestinal models important oral
drug delivery is considered the
preferred route of administration
because it's user friendly it reduces
risk of infection and reduces pain and
suffering moreover transport of drugs to
the intestinal membrane is the complex
and dynamic process and this is
important
in the candidate selection in the drug
development processes another thing to
consider is that there is really high
difficulty in controlling parameters in
in vivo model
therefore here at my Metis we developed
a simple 3d intestinal model based on
the cockatoo cells these are human
intestinal colorectal adenocarcinoma
cell line but they have a really
interesting feature that once they reach
confluency they start to differentiate
and when differentiated they resemble
anterior sides of the small intestine on
the right side you can see a face
contrast images of the tubule formations
at day one and four when they 0 the
cells are seeded against the
extracellular matrix and they start
colonizing the glass walls to form a
complaint to hear perfusion plays a
crucial role for tube formation what we
found in our culture is two bowls or
form in three days and not two more
barrier is found at bay four
you
but we can also see that not only that
they form a tubular structures this
cultures differentiate in four days
which is a surprising fact keeping in
mind that standard 2d cultures of this
self meet 17 to 21 days to do so and in
this image I'm showing you the staining
for tight junctions which is 0-1 in red
we also have the microvilli markers in
green and the nuclear are stained in
blue but this culture is also same for
different transporters like BGP route to
Mr P 2 F 1 and F 2 just to name a few
as I mentioned the be optimal barrier
function forms on day four to assess
this we use the real-time very integrity
acing in which we perfuse the
fluorescent probe with defined size
which is added in the culture media
through the lumen of the tubule when we
have a leak type tubule or fully intact
barrier the fluorescent probe are
retained in the lumen but when there is
a damage to the barrier like a toxic on
or a drugs then the fluorescent probe
clicks into the gel to the Basel site
Yeldon your higher signal in the ECM we
measure all this by time-lapse
fluorescent microscopy and we use a
quantification method where the
fluorescence level measured in the gel
region is normalized to the fluorescence
level in the tubule in the end we get
this kind of graphs where we can assess
the leak tightness of the tubule
and this is extremely important when we
are assessing drug exposures in this
image you can see the effect of a drug
concentration over time with increasing
drug concentration we can see an effect
on the very integrity even after 9 hours
of exposure while the lower
concentration of the drug don't affect
the leg tightness of the tubule even
after 24 hours
you
this type of essay was useful when we
were assessing the very integrity over
four-day-old cockatoo tables for a
nature communication paper here we
expose the tubules to a various
concentration of stars point which is a
known inducer of apoptosis over one
hundred and twenty four hours
fluorescence level were measured for
both four point four kilo daltons and
150 kilo Dalton dextran in which we
determine the liquid scores the survival
curves and the ec50 time curve which
provides an insight into both
concentration and exposure time response
in this study was comprised of 357 got
two balls with over two thousand twenty
thousand data points making in the
largest published organ on a chip data
set so far
you
but not only that we can model healthy
gut we can also model disease one in the
next slide I will show you the
application of the robust three big
katana chief model for investigating
some of hallmarks of inflammatory bowel
disease this is a term for two
conditions known as Crohn's disease and
ulcerative colitis and they are
characterized by chronic and extensive
inflammation of the gastrointestinal
tract in the Organa plate using an
immune relevant trigger we can recap
elate key aspects of IBD like
morphological changes which you can see
from the face contrast images once we
apply the inflammatory trigger and not
observed in the control to move
another key aspect of IBD is the loss of
varium folk function of the intestinal
epithelium in the top image we can
clearly see this after applying the
implementer is similar and as we can
examine further we can also observe an
activation of the intestinal epithelium
by increasing the expression of
pro-inflammatory molecules in decreasing
the expression of differentiation
markers once the trigger is supplied
so this model makes a very valuable tool
for a high throughput screen vult
involving target knockdown for example
an antenna viral viral or screen which
can be done directly in the organo plate
or with IBD specific compound
you
in the previous slides I showed you the
very integrity essay and the use of it
but we can also use a more precise way
to assess the integrity and permeability
of monolayers and that is to use the
transit patchouli oil transit the chili
electrical resistance or tear this
method is based measuring ohmic
resistance or measuring the impendence
across a wide spectrum of frequency for
this we have a new device that can
measure all of the tubules in one goal
in Indy Organa place at the same time
and it's called your ganas here
the tier measurements here are extremely
valuable when the B ISAs cannot detect
the difference in the very integrity
especially with cultures that develop a
stronger barrier integrity like
intestinal tubule
in this figure I'm just showing you the
results that we got with one of the
compounds tested in reversal of the IBD
phenotype
and we can not have only monocultures we
can also have a co culture and in this
slide I'm showing you the co culture
developed because we also wanted to have
a mucus production here we have a
monoculture of cockatoo a monoculture of
HP 29 which don't have barrier function
in a culture of cockatoo and HG 29 they
do grow and form tubules they have a
nice barrier structure and they will
sustain nicely for most of the
transporters and in these cultures we do
have a mucous production and this is
just a 3d reconstruction of the same
cultures here they're staying for the
microbial life and nuke tube which is
another mucus but not only co-cultures
in your gonna plate we have the option
to have really complex complex models
and in this slide you can see the co
culture on the top the mucus producing
one name that gap tubules and ECM we
also have incorporated self intestinal
Maya fibroblasts and in the bottom
channel we have a tube bowl of
endothelial cells perfused with immune
cells these cultures are stable for more
than 15 days and they can be used after
day seven and you can see also the
staining for their markers in the bottom
birth
the word cells you can use in your
granule plate basically any more to life
cell lines whether it's human or animal
and I just gave you some of the examples
like our co2 h2 29 or immune cells here
th P 1 and mu 2 Z 3 you can also use
primary cells like intestinal epithelium
or isolated immune cell we can also use
organic or embryonic and induced
pluripotent stem cells
and the platform is highly compatible
with all the high content imaging
systems but with also with normal
imaging systems like phase contrast
microscopy fluorescent and calm focal
and with all of the standard laboratory
equipment like absorbance and plate
readers
and is compatible with automation and
these are some of the essays that can be
used in the organo plate and since we
can also sample and have access to both
the basil and epical side of these tools
we can perform an off plate essays
[Music]
so the Organa plate can be brought to
your lab it is it has the unprecedent
vent image capacity so you can do live
imaging and there is indeed commercially
available and can be ordered from our
website
so in the end I want to thank our team
this cannot be done without their help
and also many of our collaborators and
again these are just some of the models
that can be done in your gamma plate so
thank you very much and I'm looking
forward for your question
thank you dr. now Mosca for that
informative presentation I would also
like to thank leverage for making
today's educational webcast possible now
before we go I want to let everyone know
that this webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through May of 2019
and as a final reminder our speaker will
follow up with any questions you've
submitted via email and that's all for
now thank you for joining us and we hope
to see you again soon
goodbye